par exemple l'interdit et c'est une
difficulté énorme parce que c'est bon
bah sous-munition pour la population
c'est extrêmement compliqué à gérer
derrière évidemment il y a il va y avoir
là encore des grandes discussions qui
vont se mettre en place le président
allemand par exemple à exprimer le fait
que son pays ne voulait pas bloquer les
Américains dans ses décisions et toutes
ces questions évidemment vont être plus
que jamais à l'ordre du jour d'autant
plus que la la question de la Suède
ayant été rapidement balayé hier par le
président hardwan le sommet aujourd'hui
peut se consacrer entièrement à ces
questions là